I would only be a distraction if I
stayed so where will you go
volantis good if you don't mind my
saying I don't think you should return
to Westeros I'm not sure you'd be safe
here
I will return their Spyder one last time
your lady I have to die in this strange
country what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season 8 prediction video today I want
to talk mostly about Melisandre and what
her potential endgame is during the
Great War before season 7 started I
actually made a prediction video about
the death of Melisandre and I talked
about a few different ways I thought
Melisandre could potentially die but I'm
gonna be honest with you I think I got
that prediction wrong to some extent I
initially thought someone who Melisandre
had wronged could kill her but now I
think she has a much bigger role to play
in the war to come based off a few of
her scenes from season 7 and even a few
of her scenes from earlier seasons when
I made my video about Arya Starks hit
list I talked about whether or not we
would see Melisandre again because she
was on aureus hit list for taking Gendry
away to perform her blood magic
and according to Melisandre as she did
say that her and Arya wouldn't meet
again I see a darkness in you
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me brown eyes blue eyes green eyes
eyes you'll shut forever
we will need to go I think there is a
very good chance they can still meet
again but I don't necessarily think that
means it would be the death of
Melisandre or at least not right away
after I started thinking about what
Melisandre is role could be in season 8
I ended up going back and watching
pretty much every one of her scenes to
look for any more possible clues that
might indicate how she can still be of
some use as we all know the great war
for the dawn is upon us and now that the
night king of south of the wall it's
just a matter of time before he starts
killing everyone in Westeros and adding
them to his army of the dead as of right
now the night King just brought down the
wall at eastwatch-by-the-sea and he is
making his way south as John and
Daenerys are making their way to white
Harbor where they will then travel north
to Winterfell where they can possibly
meet face to face with the night King
once again John and Daenerys no they do
not have what it takes to defeat the
night king with what they have that's
the main reason why they even went to
the dragon pit to try and get the
support from Cersei to provide her
Lannister soldiers for the great war but
we all know Cersei isn't going to even
help them and not only that she says she
has 20,000 men from the golden company
coming from Essos as her reinforcements
John was able to rally the north behind
him in season six but they don't have as
many soldiers as they once did and we
still don't know how they are going to
react when John shows up what Daenerys
Targaryen which is someone most of the
northerners hate considering all the bad
blood they've had from the past so we
could possibly see some of the
northerners turn their back on Jon Snow
I'm not saying that's gonna happen but
I'm just saying it could happen Daenerys
is providing her own solid into three
key soldiers to help John but we aren't
sure how they will be able to adapt to
the conditions in the north
the Dothraki are outstanding fighters in
the open field but they have only fought
in much warmer climates so how good will
they be when the ground is frozen and
covered in snow and the temperatures are
freezing cold as they try to fight
across the northern terrain I don't
think they're gonna fare as well as they
did during the spoils of war
Daenerys only has two dragons left as
well and we have seen just how easily
they can be taken out of the sky with
just one blow from the making spear not
to mention Daenerys said the night king
has around 100,000 whites in his army
I'm not really sure how she came up with
that number but she did have a
bird's-eye view when she
when up north on dro going so maybe she
could give an accurate estimation
there's a very good chance that John and
Daenerys can't win this war with what
they have the night King has a dragon he
has Giants and he possibly has 100,000
White's who are all built to fight in
the snow plus they still have to worry
about Cersei she still has Lannister
soldiers plus you're on in his fleet
that is about to be filled with 20,000
men from the golden company I think in
order for John and Daenerys to win both
of these wars they're gonna need some
kind of an x-factor some kind of outside
force that no one would see coming which
leads me to Melisandre Melisandre could
possibly be the key to adding some kind
of balance to this great war this is a
Song of Ice and Fire and that title
describes more than just one thing it
has been a theme throughout this entire
series and it's going to play its
biggest part in the end of this series -
the knight King has a direct connection
to ice he can actually manipulate the
ice and the powerful weapons that can
take down a dragon with one strike so we
may need something that can manipulate
the fire side of things and create a
type of weapon that the knight King
cannot stop some might say we already
have that weapon with the Dragons but I
think it's gonna take even more than
that I don't think the dragons are gonna
be the ultimate weapon in the end
Melisandre also has that direct
connection to fire she can actually see
things in the flames and she can even
manipulate fire - which could be just
some tricks but it could be more than
that and she knows she's going to be
needed in this great war she even said
as much to Jon Snow the last time that
they spoke I've been ready to die for
many years if the Lord was done with me
so be it but he's not you've seen the
night King Jon Snow you know with the
Great War still to come you know the
army of the Dead will be upon us soon
and you know I can help you win that war
she told John that he knows she can help
him win this war but the question is how
what else can Melisandre do or provide
to help John win this war at this point
I think Melisandre must have some other
kind of hidden power that we have yet to
see her use when she first met Jon back
when he was the Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch she did say
something interesting to him that may
possibly reveal exactly what she means
by being able to help him still do you
feel my heart beating this power in you
you resist it and that's your mistake
embraces the Lord of Light made us male
and female two parts of a greater home
you're not joining his power power to
make life power to make light power to
cast shadows think about what she
actually said right there - John she
asked John if he could feel her heart
beating as his hand was on her chest she
said that he has power within him but he
resists that power he needs to embrace
that power
Melisandre knew that John had Kings
blood which is why she said together
they can make life make light and cast
shadows since John has Kings blood Mel
could use him to make another shadow
baby just like she did what Stannis when
they use this power to kill Renly
Baratheon
when Melisandre says she can help John
win this war maybe she thinks that they
can make another shadow baby together
and use it to kill the night king but
what I found even more interesting in
what she said to John right there was
together they can make light now what do
you think she means when she says they
can make light together could that
possibly be another reference to light
bringer Melisandre has always been a big
believer that as aura high or the prince
that was promised would be the one to
defeat the darkness using a flaming
sword called light bringer azor Ahai is
a legendary figure who many believed was
the man who forged a hero's sword by
plunging it into the chest of Nissa
Nissa which caused it to catch fire in
combining with Nissa Nissa soul it
created the sword Lightbringer
when azor Ahai created light bringer
Nissa Nissa had to bear her breast first
which is exactly what Melisandre did
with John in that scene
Melisandre asked him if he could feel
her heart beating that could be some
foreshadowing that John will need to
plunge it into Melisandre chest to
create light bringer Melisandre said
they could create light together so
maybe this is the light that she is
referring to the legend
flaming sword we got a demonstration of
this on the beats of Dragonstone back in
season 2 in the ancient books it's
written that a warrior will draw a
burning sword from the fire
and that sword shall be Lightbringer if
you continue watching on the screen you
can see Stannis actually pull the sword
from the chest of a burning statue but
as we all know Stannis was not the one
which Melisandre later admitted but now
she believes John is the one and she may
have realized that you need an actual
living person to sacrifice themselves in
order to form Lightbringer and
Melisandre might know that the person
that needs to be sacrificed is actually
her and John is gonna need to be the one
to plunge his sword into her bare chest
and not just some statues on a beach
Melisandre has always said that death by
fire is the purest death and I think it
would be fitting if Melisandre actually
died by fire too what better way to
sacrifice herself in order for this to
happen
considering she has sacrificed so many
people force of mere said great power
requires great sacrifice this could be
why Melisandre knows she has to come
back to Westeros and die Melisandre said
she's going to volantis but she will be
back because she has to die in this
country just like Varys I talked about
Daenerys being nice and Nisa before but
now that I think about it I think there
is a much stronger case for it being
Melisandre in the show at least if
they're gonna bring Melisandre back to
this country and kill her off it has to
be in some epic fashion and I think her
sacrificing herself in order for the
knight King to finally be stopped would
be a very fitting way to end her story
she has been preaching about the prince
who was promised for many seasons now
and they keep showing us these burning
swords so I think it would make a lot of
sense if Melisandre was the one who had
to bare her breasts one last time for
Jon to plunge his sword into her making
the steel combine with her soul to
create Lightbringer they also showed
Gilly reading a page straight out of a
world of Ice and Fire and it was
actually about azor Ahai and when sam
got the Winter foe he told brand that he
knew John was going to be the one to
lead the fight against the night king so
I would be very disappointed if we
didn't get some kind of payoff to the
azure Ahai prophecy after they have been
hyping it up for years but this is just
my opinion there is another way
Melisandre could possibly help and I
think she might have hinted at this when
she met Daenerys in the throne room on
Dragonstone listen carefully to what
Melisandre actually says to Daenerys
right here the Lord of Light doesn't
have many followers in Westeros does he
not yes but even those who don't worship
the Lord conserve his cause
Daenerys said the Lord of Light doesn't
have many followers in Westeros but
Melisandre said not yet which makes me
think more are about to arrive which
could be another reason why Melisandre
left for volantis the followers aren't
here yet because Melisandre is going to
get them now this all depends on what
the show decides to include in their
version of this story but in volantis
where Melisandre is going there is a
group of slave soldiers called the fury
hand and they're the ones who guard the
red temple of reward in the free city of
volantis there is a high priest at this
temple named banheiro
who is a strong supporter of Daenerys in
the books but in the show I believe they
actually gave this role to kin Varro who
was the High Priestess that tyrion
brought to marine when tyrion met what
can Vora he said he was going to try and
persuade her into supporting Daenerys
but kin vara cut him off and said he
doesn't need to persuade her because she
already believes that Daenerys is the
chosen one the princess who was promised
and we have still yet to get any kind of
closure what can vara yet and now that
Melisandre is going to volantis there is
a strong possibility that they team up
together and come back to Westeros was
some kind of plan or even a force of the
fury hand as far as I can remember the
fury hand only consists of about a
thousand men never more never less but
this could be a nice addition to help in
this war against the night king one cool
thing about these soldiers are their
weapons they use Spears that have a
flame on the end of them the exact
opposite of what the knight King and the
White Walkers use can you imagine seeing
the White Walkers and the men of the
fury hand running into battle at each
other one side with ice Spears in the
other side with fire Spears I think that
would look pretty badass in my opinion
plus it would be kind of cool having the
knight King on one side of the
battlefield and having Melisandre and
conveyor and whoever else they bring
with them on the other side of the
battlefield we could see people being
risen from the dead on both sides fire
white sand ice whites I would love to
see the look on the night Kings face if
he saw someone else bringing someone
back from the dead
it would probably turn him on and have
him thinking that needs to be his Nights
queen someone else who has the power to
raise the dead who knows but things can
get very interesting if we get to see
the red guards show its true strength
during this war for the dawn but before
I go too far
down tinfoil' road let me just send this
video right here I want to thank all of
you for watching today's video I
appreciate that as always and I hope to
see you all come back for the next one I
also want to thank the supporters of
this channel from patreon have a great
day everyone I will see you down in the
comment section bye
you